what are springboards and sequences
so i did not invent springboards and
sequences and
unfortunately i can't remember where i
picked this up but i think it's a really
useful thing
when you're trying to figure out kind of
that
well it's really useful when you're
trying to figure out act 2 right because
it allows you to break your story down
into smaller chunks
so sequences a lot of people have heard
of
you can think of your movie as sort of
eight sequences
two sequences in act one four sequences
in act two
two sequences in act three right so
that's sort of the division of sequences
across your three-act structure
um it's it's pretty common to look at
movies in sort of that sequence
structure
the springboards i think are the real
bonus of of this
exercise that i sort of help writers
with which is
coming up with that um that event or
turning point or plot point
that ends one sequence and launches the
next one and that
it's just a way for you to sort of start
planning out your story so that there's
a real sense of cause and effect
and it breaks it down into manageable
chunks when you
are plotting or even when you're writing
um i do this and i
i teach this method which is uh to
outline
in sequences so you only have to focus
on one sequence at a time
which makes it less daunting to approach
your your entire story
if we were to look at crash and i know
you said that that was one of the most
difficult of the
50 or you know yeah great awesome film
but yeah in terms of the structure
what would be some of those springboards
that's a good question i haven't
actually seen crash in so long
that it would be tough but i will say if
you're if you're looking at
sort of um the way springboards and
sequences
overlay onto onto the three-act
structure right and it does it
they they line right up and it's um i'm
certainly not saying that every movie
has to have eight equal sequences across
the movie but this is just a method to
help you
to help you plot your story and you may
deviate from this
as you find your story right so every
story is unique you have to serve that
story the story that you're telling
but it gives you a starting point so if
i if i am coming out of story and i just
really don't know anything yet
i start thinking in the springboards and
sequences because that gives me
sort of containers to think about what
needs to happen in each section of the
script
um and then as i find what needs to
happen in each section i might go oh
i only need one sequence here i only
need you know maybe i need three short
sequences here or whatever
but it just gives you a starting point
to sort of break your story
um and then if you're uh we were talking
about
what it you know what is a springboard
and sort of where do they fall
um your kind of big turning points
naturally
are springboards so your inciting
incident is your first springboard right
so you have a sequence of your story
that's
going to be all set up really
introducing your protagonist
establishing the world all that stuff
what's their life like right now
and then that sequence will end in the
inciting incident which is a springboard
that launches the next sequence so
because of that inciting incident
your protagonist now has some sort of
problem or opportunity that they're
going to have to deal with right
and that is what sequence 2 is about so
it's like what are they going to do with
this how are they going to contend with
it
what happens if they don't deal with it
what's at stake you know all that stuff
closing all those like sort of immediate
doors to convince us that they're going
to take that act
ii journey so you work through that
sequence and then that
ends in the next springboard which is
your break into two right
so then you have a big sort of plot turn
at that
moment which is usually your protagonist
deciding yes i'm gonna go do this thing
here's my plan for solving this big
problem in my life that's your
springboard that launches you into
sequence three
so so the the sort of um springboard and
sequences
that we use as like a framework to sort
of to start figuring out your story
really just lays on top of 3x structure
and a lot of your major turning points
that you have
probably already thought of those are
going to be springboards anyway
so if i was going to take let's say
going back to this librarian with the
with the bad boy um boyfriend i like
this story
too if she let's suppose she's called
into the administrator's office for this
central library and they say
i need to have a seat uh listen um we do
not
advocate um dating people that are
within our programs here
and is that a springboard or her
springboard would then be to make a
decision
let's suppose she's still allowed to
keep her job but she's been given
like a reprimand and it's going in her
file
what part would actually be a
springboard well so um i actually think
it's both of those things so it's the
event
that turns the story in a new direction
or launches the next sort of sequence of
events
but that is going to be led off by your
character's reaction to that event so
it might be um you know she she's sat
down by her
superior they say you have a choice you
can either
um keep your job or keep the guy and
then her reaction to that is
is really what we're watching over the
next sequence so that sequence is going
to start with her
probably making some sort of decision
right
um it'll probably probably be in the
next scene
or it might not um but
long story short the springboard would
would be the event and then her reaction
to it would be what
what would be tracking over the next
sequence probably
right okay because let's say then she
goes like on the subway and maybe she
sees couples together
and she's kind of like sizing up like
hmm
is this where i fit in to couple them
with like you know i've
chosen someone that's maybe outside my
circle of friends yeah
well so that's actually a good example
because i think that it um
the the options that you brought up it
could work both ways so the springboard
could be
she sat down and told you have to make
this choice and then the next sequence
might be
about us watching her make that choice
right or that the next sequence might be
after she she walks out of that office
knowing she's going to
ditch the job and go with the guy then
the next sequence might be
her trying to convince him that they're
in it together and
there's no one else and whatever you
know what i mean so it just kind of
depends on your story
um that's why i said it's just a it's
just a framework to sort of help us you
know fig
start breaking your story and think
about like what needs to happen in each
c in each um section of your story great
yeah
thank you okay great yeah this script is
coming together and i'm not even gonna
you